il y a 6 ans ça me nourrit arrivait en
france abandonnée devant la gare de
tours par un passeurs sans scrupules
après avoir fui l'afghanistan il avait
alors 14 ans aujourd'hui ça me nourrit à
20 ans et est en passe de devenir l'un
des stylistes les plus doués de sa
génération
il vient d'obtenir la nationalité
française tout un symbole
c'est un gros soulagement quel joli en
fait depuis longtemps que j'attendais ça
et voilà on m'a construit un peu en fait
je me sens lire je peux faire ce que
j'ai envie de faire et avancer vraiment
dans un projet comme il faut présent
dans les salons de la préfecture pour ce
moment si émouvant sa maman son ancien
proviseur du lycée professionnel
françois cloué mais aussi la famille
strauch qui l'a accueilli chez elle tous
les week-ends pendant deux ans ses
terres que c'était
un objectif quand même et puis en tant
que chef d'entreprise je suis très
content que ça me soit français que je
pense que la france a gagné quelque
chose aujourd'hui avec tous ces gens qui
et c'est très émouvant
ancien élève de john galliano puis de
jean paul gaultier
ça me nourrit devrait créer sa griffe
d'ici la fin de l'année
avant cela il présentera son tout
premier défilé haute couture à fougères
en bretagne les 14 15 et 16 juillet
prochain